ou peu plus d'internet nous sommes donc
le 3 décembre
si la troisième ouverture de ce
calendrier de l'avent je rappelle le
principe beat feuz oui non oui un petit
peu une vidéo tous les jours à 6 heures
du matin où je parle un peu beaucoup
trop peut-être
mais également où je vous présente un
truc que je chante if moi dans ma vie et
aujourd'hui c'est un jeu qui s'appelle
exit qui est de toutes les vidéos que
vous allez voir sur ce mode descendre
mon jeu préféré de cette année c'est mon
île de cette année voilà que ce soit dit
que ce soit bien clair c'est ça alors il
ya un gros défaut je vous en parlerai à
la fin je vais vous parler des avantages
du jeu c'est une boîte à l'intérieur de
quel tu trouves un escape game principe
d'un escape game mais que tu peux faire
seul chez toi et ça je trouve ça
vraiment brillant certes à un petit
livret de règles une sorte de spatules
décodeur c'est le créateur non en
garçonne spatule décodeur bon bref les
règles du jeu qui sont toujours le même
d'une boîte à l'autre et ensuite trois
styles de cartes des cartes énigmes sur
lequel vous trouverez un indice chez
vous en bas de votre écran
une énigme c'est ça des cartes réponse
qui est pour vérifier que tu as trouvé
la bonne réponse à l'énigme
mais ça ne te donne pas la réponse c'est
juste en fonction du code que tu va
décoder tu vas pouvoir voir si c'est la
bonne réponse ou pas et des cartes aide
donc qu'il a toujours deux ailes par
énigmes et la réponse si vraiment tu
galères donc tu poses tout ça devant toi
et tu suis un peu ton livre et de départ
qui au départ tu as là un petit peu las
loric des indices des choses comme ça à
chaque fois que tu vois une carte
henning tulard tourner tu la prends tu
lis l'énigme nous sommes un exemple
concret là c'est l'énigme w qui nous dit
henri de trouver le code
n'hésitez pas à plier ne voyez vous pas
la ligne bleue tout ce que tu as étage
se livrer ici
donc tu prends le livre est une fille
éthiques abbas a aucun endroit tu ya une
ligne bleue et donc comme on parle donc
du grand vide
les jeux clearing bleus et j'arrive sur
le code 106 et je vais essayer de le
décoder je vais voir ça m'emmène
ailleurs acté ce jeu est clairement le
truc qui m'amuse le plus est que j'ai
trouvé le plus brillant dans la création
cette année parce que tu peux te faire
tout l'équivalent d'un escalier mais
sans bloquer grâce aux cartes aide en te
chronométrant ou pas mais tu as une
vraie sensation d'immersion pendant 60
minutes ou 90 minutes tu décides si tu
prends les indices ou pas si tu vas
aller plus ou moins vite c'est c'est
génial c'est brillant ils ont sorti
trois opus vous recommande pour
commencer de commencer par celui ci la
cabane abandonnée
je trouve que c'était le plus simple
d'en comprendre les mécanismes et après
vous avez aussi le tombeau du pharaon et
le laboratoire secret et j'ai vraiment
vraiment vraiment hâte qu'ils en sont
d'autres alors il ya un truc aussi cool
c'est que tu dois te découper parfois
les caves griffonné dessus écrire dessus
c'est vraiment lui tu joues au jeu avec
toutes les possibilités que ça ouvre et
le seul point négatif c'est que c'est du
coup c'est one shot
tu peux y jouer qu'une fois il ya qu une
seule énigme évidemment donc tu vas t'en
servir qu'une seule fois et même après
pour le donner à quelqu'un si compliqué
puisque tu auras parfois découper les
cartes ou ce genre de choses ça c'est le
seul truc qui est dommage
après dans les autres choses
intéressantes tu as des objets qui vont
permettre de résoudre des énigmes et on
te dit quand est-ce que tu les découvre
pas le storytelling est soigné
l'immersion est soigné et est à fond
dedans
si tu joues chez toi avec musique
d'ambiance les pas trop de lumière tu
peux vraiment éclaté j'ai bouffé les
trois à une vitesse folle alors du coup
sûr le point négatif kiliwa moquer mais
ça coûte
je sais pas combien d'ailleurs vous avez
pris juste ici ça coûte ce prix là et du
coup c'est dommage parce que je m'en
sert qu'une fois je pense qu'il faut le
considérer un peu comme une place de
cinéma ou une activité
tu vois quand tu vas payer tant pour
aller faire une heure de paintball ou
pour aller faire un prêt et quelle game
bah c'est un peu le même délire pour le
voir vraiment comme ça mais voilà c'est
bon c'est mon coup de coeur best de
l'année bravo aux auteurs bravo à la
maison d'édition seguer l'eau qui font
des super jeu aussi comme time bomb etc
c'est le truc que j'ai le plus qui fait
je crois qu'on a bien compris je la sais
dit si ça vous plaît vous avez toutes
les infos dans la barre d'infos dans la
description si vous guérir à les trouver
c'est juste en dessous d'une autre idée
pour noël qui une place à l'olympia pour
le 22 septembre 2008 ça reste une
excellente idée rappelons que vous
pouvez cliquer la vidéo vous pouvez
également vous abonner et je vous aurais
dit demain jeudi de ma quoi de ma rendez
vous demain rendez vous à 6 heures
on
[Musique]